We finished black boy last time and one
of the big questions coming out of my
discussion of that autobiography is how
do you manage the question of context
and reading a novel, a or an
autobiography in reading any texts.
And we had a very complex publishing
history to think about, um,
with that text.
Flannery O'connor's work raises
questions of a similar kind,
but they look very
different. And so my, um,
my lectures on Flannery O'connor,
we'll highlight the methodologies that
we can bring to any reading of a novel,
um,
and it will highlight the differences
between different methodologies and what
they allow us to see in a different texts.
Okay.
Flannery O'connor, as most of you
probably know, is a southern writer.
Um,
she's very often assimilated to a whole
group of southern writers who were
working in the 1930s and forties.
The southern Agrarians. Um,
she was friends with a lot of the
major figures of that movement,
especially Allen Tate and,
um, Carolyn, uh, Gordon,
she,
uh,
lived out her life mostly in a small
town called Milledgeville, Georgia.
She was born in Savannah in 1925.
Um,
she studied writing at the
Iowa writer's workshop.
She lived in New York for a short time,
but she was afflicted with Lupus,
a very serious illness and she died at
the age of 39 and 1964 so she lived a
pretty short life. Um, over
the course of that life,
she wrote mostly short stories and so
she's very much known for her short
stories. Um, she has a couple
of novels of them. This is,
I think the most successful,
uh,
oh Connor,
you may also know has been
understood as a religious writer.
She was a Catholic and she very much
made her Catholicism at the center of all
the things that she said
about her fictional practice.
And so we're going to see a couple
of those things. Uh, uh, today.
Let's look just to begin with,
if you brought your books, um,
well actually let's look
at the cover of this book.
What does this cover say to you?
What does this image remind you of?
What does it look like to you
want to answer that part?
It's the sacred heart. Yes. It's
the sacred heart of Jesus in,
in Catholic iconography of a certain
kind of the figure of Christ is shown,
usually partying his clothes and his
flesh and showing you his sacred heart,
which is usually crowned
with flame and often,
um, encircled with thorns.
So it's an image of Christ,
the suffering Godhead,
the very human fleshly person who will
part his own flesh in order to connect
with in order to redeem,
um, the, the believer.
So right in the packaging of
this novel that we have today,
this cover has changed over time.
Um, nevertheless, even today,
that very Catholic iconography is
right on the front of the cover.
And when you see why his blood,
that title right below the sacred heart,
you can't help but think of,
well,
this is blood is somehow
the blood of Christ.
That's the kind of blood
we're talking about.
It's already entered a sort
of metaphorical register
religious register in the
way this book is packaged.
Then when we open up the front,
we see the author's note to the second
edition and this was something O'Connor
added to the novel, uh, in 1962.
I just want to read that with you today.
She says, why is blood has reached
the age of 10 and is still alive?
My critical powers are just sufficient
to determine this and I am gratified to
be able to say it.
The book was written with Zest and if
possible it should be read that way.
It is a comic novel about a Christian
Mal Gray Louie and as such very serious
for all comic novels that are any good
must be about matters of life and death.
Wise blood was written by an author,
congenitally innocent of theory,
but one with certain preoccupations.
That belief in Christ is to some a matter
of life and death has been a stumbling
block for readers who would prefer to
think it a matter of no great consequence
for them.
Hazel motes integrity lies in his
trying with such vigor to get rid of the
ragged figure who moves from tree
to tree in the back of his mind.
For the author Hazel's integrity
lies in his not being able to do so.
So right up front we are told that
Hazel motes is a Christian in spite of
himself.
That this is how we are to understand
this character who we will come to know.
I also want to sort of give another layer
to this understanding of O'connor as a
religious writer by looking at what she
said in her car respondence to one of
her readers who asked her some questions.
And this is on the handout
that I passed around.
This is a letter to a man
named Ben Griffith from 1954.
So she had just finished wise blood
and people are starting to read it,
ask her questions.
She was a prolific correspondence.
She was very generous
in her letter writing.
She would write to almost
anyone who wrote to her.
She would write back in a substantive way.
Um,
I think it's in part that
I'm suffering from Lupus.
She was very much confined to her house
in Georgia and the letter writing,
this kind of correspondence was certainly
way for her to keep in contact, um,
with the, with the world of readers
and, and other writers and friends.
So he had written to her, um, he
was teaching writing at a local, uh,
college.
He's obviously been asking her about
the sources of some of the images and
characters and themes in wise blood.
So I want to point out a couple of things.
This is the first full paragraph.
I don't know how to cure the sore situs
except to tell you that I can discover a
good many possible sources
myself for wise blood.
But I am often embarrassed to
find that I read the sources,
I read the sources after
I had written the book.
I have been exposed to
Wordsworth's intimation owed.
But that is all I can say about it.
I have one of those food chopper brains
that nothing comes out of the way it
went in. The Oedipus business comes
nearer to home. Of course, haze.
Motes is not an Oedipus figure,
but there are obvious resemblances at
the time I was writing the last of the
book, I was living in Connecticut,
actually very close here at Yale and uh,
one of the, uh, people who is
still at Yale, Penny Laurans,
I don't know if you've met her,
she's someone who, who knew, uh,
she was married to Robert Fitzgerald
and she knew Flannery O'connor. Um,
uh, when I was living in Connecticut
with the Robert Fitzgerald's,
Robert Fitzgerald translated the Fiba
and cycle and cycle with Dudley fits in
the translation of Oedipus rex had just
come out and I was much taken with it.
Um, anyway, all I can say is I did
a lot of thinking about Oedipus.
This is very typical in tone for O'connor
when she talks about education or
learning. And if you read
more in this letter, I won't
go through the whole thing.
Um, you will see that she's
very self deprecating.
She says she has what passes for
an education in this day and age.
She says that she's read a little bit of
Kafka and doesn't know what to make of
him,
but it makes you a bolder writer.
She reads a little Henry James Cause she
thinks that makes her a better writer
somehow,
but she doesn't quite know how.
There's always this veneer of innocence
or lack of learning or lack of
sophistication.
Um,
so she's presenting
herself as a simple person.
I think that's important,
although not directly connected to her
presentation of herself as a Catholic
person.
I think it does factor into her sense
that the truth she is accessing or the
truth that she is trying to present to
the world in her stories is one that uh,
even a child might be able to understand
that that fits very comfortably within
a new testament understanding
of the teaching of Christ.
So Christ is that one to whom
the little children can come.
And I think she cultivates that,
uh,
that childlike sense in
herself presentation.
But then there's this very explicit
discussion of her Catholicism.
Little further down my background and
my inclinations are both Catholic and I
think this is very apparent in the book.
Something is usually said about
Kafka in connection with wise blood,
but I've never succeeded in making my
way through the castle or the trial and I
wouldn't pretend to know
anything about Kafka.
I think reading a little of him perhaps
makes you a boulder writer and so on.
If you turn over, this is another, um,
this is another letter to Ben Griffith.
Um,
written fairly shortly
after this first one.
She expands a little bit on
this sense of her Catholicism.
This is in the middle of the page.
Let me assure you that no one but a
Catholic could've written wise blood even
though it is a book about
a kind of Protestant St,
it reduces Protestantism to the twin
ultimate absurdities of the church without
Christ or the Holy Church of Christ
without Christ, which no po Protestant,
pious, pious Protestant
would do. And of course,
no unbeliever or agnostic could have
written it because it is entirely
redemption centered in thought.
Not Too many people are willing to
see this and perhaps it is hard to see
because Hazel motes is
such an admirable nihilist.
His nihilism leads him back to the
fact of his redemption, however,
which is what he would have
liked so much to get away from.
When you start describing the significance
of a symbol like the tunnel which
recurs in the book, you immediately
begin to limit it and assemble,
should go on deepening everything
should have a wider significance.
But I am a novelist, not a critic,
and I can excuse myself from x Xsplit,
Casio xsplit on to text on that ground.
The real reason of course,
is laziness. There's that, that,
uh, characteristics self-deprecation
with letters like this,
which were published,
uh,
copiously in a,
in a beautiful addition that
Sarah Sally Fitzgerald edited, um,
with letters like this,
her frequent essays and lectures which
are collected in a book called mystery
and manners.
She was expounding a certain reading
of her fiction even while she was still
writing it.
And those who were close
to her have picked up that
understanding of her fiction
and promulgated it.
And there's a huge critical
industry around Flannery O'Connor.
And at the core of it is a body of
criticism that fines and articulate and
explains the religious
meanings of her texts.
With that in mind,
I want to point up to the two quotations
that I put on the board to start us off
today. Um, I like his eyes.
They don't look like they see what he's
looking at, but they keep on looking.
This is Sabbath, Lily Hawks and then, uh,
a character you haven't met yet.
If you stopped at page 100 Ani j holy,
I wouldn't have you believe nothing.
You can't feel in your own hearts.
These two quotations seem to me a kind
of rubric under which we can start to
think about what it means to read this
novel and what it means to read it in the
light of the religious
context that O'connor herself,
critics,
marketers have built up around her work.
The first quotation from
Sabbath Lilly of course,
focuses on the eyes and it,
it is not hard to read into haze,
motes,
his name,
that the trope of site is going
to be important haze motes.
There's that famous passage in the
new testament or is it, oh gosh,
now I'm going to forget if it's new or Old
Testament, someone will correct me. Um,
uh, do not try to remove the
moat from your neighbor's eye,
uh, before you have removed
it from your own or less.
You failed to remove the
moat from your own eye.
So there's this sense of
occluded site haze that Hayes,
somehow something is wrong with haze,
motes his eyes,
something wrong with his site or rather
there is something important about his
site that we're going to have to unpack.
But what I want to take out of Sabbath,
Lily's comment about Hays is
this sense of what you look at.
What does Hayes look at
and what does he see,
what do we look at when we read
this novel and what do we see?
Those are questions that are going to
frame the two lectures that I give on this
novel.
The second quotation from Ani j holy
raises the question of sentiment.
This novel as you will soon see once
you get to the parts where Ani j holy
begins to preach this novel is very
much a critique of sentimentality.
If Richard Wright's ideal response to
his fiction was that for the reader,
the words would disappear and all they
would be left with is their emotional
response.
For O'Connor,
it's precisely that kind of
response to any call be a textual,
be it an active reading and active
audition. Hearing someone preach.
That kind of response is precisely
not the one you are supposed to have.
And so I would ask you to think about a
couple of simple questions as you move
through this book. And as you think
about what I have to say about it, um,
one of them could begin
with a reflection like this.
Would you ever want to sit down to dinner
with any of the people in this novel?
I see people shaking their heads,
they are quite unlikable
and this is consistent pretty much
across O'Connor's fiction, short, long,
medium,
whatever.
Her characters are not very endearing.
So you want to ask yourself why that's,
so this is a conscious decision on her
part and you want to think about that
decision. If there's any character
who seems kind of endearing, uh,
at least for me it's probably Enoch.
Um,
and we'll talk a little
bit more about him. Um,
not today but in the second
lecture and in section.
So with these questions in mind,
I want you to think about
how we can see the novel
and how we can think about it in the
face of the interpretation that's already
layered onto it.
And what I want to do is now kind of
just descend into the text and read with
you the passage when Hays first
takes the Essex out for a spin,
his, his wonderful car, the Essex. Um,
so this is on page 73 is
about where it begins.
And I'm going to read through the next
two or three pages and I'll skip around
in the book as things come up that I want
to show you in other parts of the book.
So let's think about seeing and theology
and all the issues that are already on
the table for us.
I'm going to begin at the bottom of 73
when the car was ready, if you have
your book, go ahead and open it up.
When the car was ready,
the man and the boy stood by
to watch him drive it off.
Is it the wrong page
numbers? Shoot. Oh dear.
69 okay,
so it's four off.
Okay.
Thank you for telling me.
You rely on publishers and
then they let you tell them.
Okay. Does everyone, everyone
have it? When the car was ready,
the man and the boys stood
by to watch him drive it off.
He didn't want anybody watching him
because he hadn't driven a car in four or
five years. The man in the boy didn't
say anything while he tried to start it.
They only stood there looking in at him.
I wanted this car mostly to be a
house for me. He said to the man,
I ain't got any place to be.
You ain't took the break off yet.
The man said he took the
break off in the car,
shot backwards because the man had
left it in reverse in a second.
He got it going forward and drove off.
Crookedly pass the man and boys
still standing there watching.
He kept going forward
thinking nothing and sweating.
So I'm going to stop there for a minute.
Haze sees the car as a kind of home.
Well,
how are we meant to understand
the meaning of that?
It has the feeling of a rare
moment of explanation from Hayes.
He almost never explains
himself to other people.
Here he is accounting
for his need for the car.
Now of course,
O'connor was very good at
imbuing her writing with repeated symbols
that grow and accrue meaning across
the text.
So we've already seen the trope of the
house and if you look back at 24 oh now
it's tried 20 see if we can find it here.
When Hays
describes or we sort of know through his
consciousness the story of his time in
the army,
this is what we learn
about how he felt there.
After he's wounded,
he had all the time he could want to
study his soul in and assure himself that
it was not there.
When he was thoroughly convinced,
he saw that this was
something he had always known.
The misery he had was a longing for home.
It had nothing to do with Jesus.
When the army finally let him go,
he was pleased to think that
he was still uncorrupted.
All he wanted was to get back to Rod,
Tennessee,
the Black Bible and his mother's glasses.
We're still in the bottom of his duffle
bag. He didn't read any book now,
but he kept the Bible because
it had come from home.
He kept the glasses in case his
vision should ever become dim.
Okay.
Oh,
Connor has already put in place in
the novel through that little passage,
the sense that the longing for home
and the longing for redemption
or the resistance to redemption,
these things are very
close to one another.
You can mistake here we,
we find out about Hayes.
You can mistake the longing for Jesus
for the longing for home or vice versa.
The longing for home for
the long name of Jesus.
The Bible that he carries
around is important to him
because it comes from home.
I want to suggest to you that the fact
that it's the religious book for him,
for his culture,
for his family,
is not of course incidental to the fact
that it's what reminds him of home.
It's not just that you can
mistake the longing for, for home,
for the longing for Jesus.
You can in some ways see
religion and home as conflated,
and this gets to a sort of traditional
Christian notion of the believer as not
being at home in the world,
that the believers somehow belongs to
God's kingdom and that this is either
countercultural at odds with the general
world in which he or she would find
herself or it is totally incompatible
with the world in which we live.
Okay.
The Bible is a physical manifestation of
the proximity of the spiritual and the
material in this world.
So what makes him feel close to home in
a way has to make him feel close to the
religion he's trying to reject.
That conflation is part of what makes
it impossible for Hays to escape the
question of redemption.
Even if he wants to answer it in a way
that's at odds with how, for example,
his grandfather,
the preacher would answer it.
This is why he's continually mistaken
for a preacher. No matter what he does.
Remember he goes into the, into
the prostitute's house, Mrs. Watts,
and he's got a hat on and the hat
just makes him look like a preacher.
There's nothing he can do. He says,
I'm not a preacher. And he says,
that's okay if you will,
if you're not a preacher.
It's just something that's in his body.
It's physical.
So the car,
going back to the passage I was
talking about before with the Essex,
the car, even though religion is
not mentioned directly right here,
the sense of home that it embodies
carries with it all that sense of unhoused
newness.
And because it's a moving house,
it carries the sense of the
wandering believer with it as well.
And you get that reinforced
on the very next page.
If you just, um, skip over
about a page from there,
a black pickup truck turned off a side
rose at road in front of him on the back
of it,
an iron bed and a chair and table were
tied and on top of them a crate of Barb
rock chickens. So other cars
on the road look like houses,
mobile houses as well.
It's not just Hayes's Essex
that is imagined as home.
So O'Connor is giving us a version of
the road and I want you to keep this in
mind because of course we're going to
read on the road and we're going to see a
major road trip in Lolita,
actually two of them. So the,
the iconography of the American road is
something that is going to come back to
us.
Well here's our first example.
This is the road of the unhoused of the
spiritually seeking of the wandering of
the last.
People wander in search of
some kind of coherent meaning
what to now move down a little bit and
observe how landscape is presented to us.
This is after that,
since he was going very fast,
the highway was ragged with filling
stations and trailer camps and roadhouses.
After awhile there were stretches where
red gullies dropped off on either side
of the road and behind them there were
patches of field button together with six,
six, six posts. The Sky
leaked all over, all of it.
And then it began to leak into the car.
The head of a string of pigs appeared,
snowed up over the ditch and he had to
screeched to a stop and watch the rear of
the last pig disappears,
shaking into the ditch on the other side.
He started the car again and went on.
He had the feeling that everything he
saw was a broken off piece of some giant
blank thing he had forgotten
had happened to him.
Yeah.
So what do we notice about this landscape?
First of all,
it's very much constructed.
It's buttoned together with
posts as if someone had built it.
And what's more, these are
described as six, six, six posts.
I think this is a probably
a size of lumber. Um,
but you can't get away from the,
uh,
the mythology of that number
in the book of revelation.
It's the number of the beast.
It's the number of the devil.
It's also a landscape
that is full of pigs,
wandering pigs.
So if the people are
wandering through this road,
the pigs are equally wanderers,
um, throughout these fields.
They're unconfined they seem
to cross the road at will.
Yeah.
The Sky,
the world above is really
bound up with the world below.
There's very little separation.
Even if there is a sense that the sky
is impinging on the earth and not the
other way around,
the sky leaked over all of it.
It's really in a sense, the physical
images of rain. It's raining,
so it's leaking all over it. But there's
more than that. There's this sense of,
um, the concerns of the sky.
Somehow the concerns of the above,
the concerns of the transcendent are
seeping their way into the concerns of the
material world below.
And then you get that sort of
lyrical moment of interpretation.
He had the feeling that everything he
saw was a broken off piece of some giant
blank thing he had forgotten
had happened to him.
Now this is where the omniscient narrator
comes in quite forcefully and gives us
something to work on as we analyze
Hayes and we think about who he is as a
character and where he finds himself.
This connects I think with a whole host
of other passages that have to do with
nothingness.
And one of them is right above on that
page and I read it a little earlier
thinking nothing and sweating.
It's as if thinking nothing.
It's not a passive
activity but an active one.
So that to think nothing is
something you have to work at.
It's something that you can be
preoccupied with. And similarly,
if you look back, um,
at 37, this is again,
uh,
a description of landscape.
You can see this connection between
or well as somewhat of a disconnection
between the above and the below.
Another description of sky,
this is Hazel.
I'm walking in talking to him.
The black sky was underpinned
with long silver streaks.
This is the very beginning of chapter
three for trying to find it that looked
like scaffolding and depth on depth behind
it were thousands stars that all seem
to be moving very slowly as if they were
about some vast construction work that
involved the whole order of the universe
and would take all time to complete.
No one was paying any attention to the sky
here.
That omniscient narrator as when that
narrator looks into Hayes's mind offers
you a reading of the sky
and it's separation from
the minds of the characters
that suggests or makes you
look for kinds of structure.
Here it's the construction work.
She actually uses that word,
but you get scaffolding.
You get depth or perspective counting.
Thousands of stars moving as if they were
about some vast work that involve the
whole order of the universe.
It volts,
the very concrete materiality,
the physicality of these
characters in their circumstances.
It vaults that discussion into a much
larger metaphysical transcendent context.
The whole order of the universe.
It's moments like these when that
omniscient narrator lives up to its name,
that sense of omniscience that
we might associate with God.
Another example is that the
very opening of the book,
the train was racing through tree tops
that fell away at intervals and showed
the son's standing very red on the edge
of the farthest woods near the plowed
fields,
curved and faded and a few and the few
hogs nosing in the furrows looked like
large spotted stones.
Mrs Wally be Hitchcock who was facing
moats in the section said that she thought
the early evening like this was the
prettiest time of day and she asked him if
he didn't think so.
Too pretty is not exactly
the word that comes to mind,
at least not to my mind when I read this.
It's more like heavy or
saturated and there's again,
pigs running around.
Again,
there's a biblical iconography
behind this that uh,
there are two instances
that come to my mind. Um,
when demons are cast out by the apostles
and sent into a herd of pigs and the
pigs go running off a cliff and die,
that's one image.
Another is the um,
the admonition not to throw
your pearls before swine,
not to preach to those who can't
hear or won't be perceptive.
So these moments of landscape description
offer up that consistently Christian
inflected theory of the universe,
that sense of transcendence as structure,
as something that's moving inexorably
that we'll take all time to complete.
It has a,
it has a teleology,
so that's present in all of these moments.
But equally present, I want to get
back to this sense of blankness.
There's a vagueness to this language
that I think is quite calculated and it
relates in Hayes's case to
his determination to not
be converted to evil but to
nothing.
When he's in the army,
he says he decides he can get rid
of Jesus by converting not evil,
but to but to nothing,
to believe in nothing.
So what O'Connor does is she presents a
sense of the world imbued with structure
and meaning, but a structure and
meaning that looks essentially blank.
And I think the task of the novel
is to fill that structure in.
Yeah.
The last thing I want to point out in
this passage from here to the end of the
chapter is the way that
Hayes's senses are described.
We already talked a little bit about
his name and the occlusion of sight.
The trope of site is
obviously extremely important.
Here we have the blind preacher. Um, there
are more things which I won't reveal.
Uh, that happened at the end of the novel
to do with this. If you haven't read,
I won't give it away,
but here there are simpler examples.
When the truck pulls up in front of
haze and starts moving very slowly,
he's started pounding his horn and he
had hit it three times before he realized
it didn't make any sound.
He keeps doing this.
When he comes to the roadside sign,
woe to the blast femur and
whoremonger we'll hell swallow you up.
Says the pickup truck slowed even more
as if it were reading. The sign in.
Hayes pounded his empty horn.
He beat on it and beat on it,
but it didn't make any sound.
He
doesn't at first hear
the horn fail to blow.
Yeah.
And then later when a car pull,
a truck pulls up behind him,
he fails to hear a horn that does blow.
He was looking at the sign and he
didn't hear the horn. An oil truck,
as long as the railroad car
was behind him in a second,
a red square face was at his car window.
It watched the back of his
neck and hat for a minute,
and then a hand came in
and sat on his shoulder.
The driver's expression in his hand
stayed exactly the way they were,
as if he didn't hear very well.
These two characters are as if
there is a a wall between them,
a wall of foam.
They can't hear each other.
They're insulated from understanding
what the other is preoccupied with.
In Hayes's case,
he does this over and over and over again,
and the most pitiful
example of it is on 57.
Poor Ethan Hawke feel so bad for
him in this. In this passage,
Enoch is trying to hang out with Hayes.
Um,
this is on the bottom
of 56 probably your 52
he's trying to get, he's just
trying to get rid of Enoch. Listen,
Hayes said roughly. I got business
of my own. I seen all of you I want,
he began walking very fast in our,
kept skipping steps to keep up.
I've been here two months. He
said, and I don't know, and nobody,
people ain't friendly here. I got me a
room and there ain't never nobody in it,
but me. My Daddy said I had to come. I
would never have come, but he made me,
I think I seen you summers before. You
ain't from Stockwell our, you know.
Millsy no saw mill set.
They're set up there once,
you know at said look like you
had kind of a familiar face.
They walked on without saying anything
until they got to the main street again.
It was almost deserted. Goodbye Hayes
said, I'm going this way to, you know,
at sadness in salon voice on the left.
There was a movie house with the electric
bill was being changed and then I'm
going to skip down. My daddy made
me come. He said in a crack voice.
Hayes looked at him and saw he was crying.
His face seemed and wet and purple,
purple, pink color. I ain't but 18
years old. He cried and he made me calm.
And I don't know nobody.
Nobody here,
I'll have nothing to do with
nobody else name friendly.
He done gone off with a
woman and made me come,
but she ain't gonna stay for
long. Okay. And so on and so on.
Poor EasyKnock. Does Hayes
Care? No, not at all.
He's looked straight ahead
with his face set. Poor Enoch.
Nothing can penetrate Hayes's
imperviousness to other human beings.
If Hayes is busy looking at something,
what he's looking at is manifestly
not the person in front of him.
He can't hear major
elements of the soundscape.
The car horn behind the truck horn
behind him. He can't hear his own horn.
Whether it blows or not,
he can't hear the voices of other people.
What he sees is a mystery as Sabbath.
Lily says they don't his eyes,
they don't look like they
see what he's looking at.
What is he looking at them I think
were meant to understand that he is so
focused on the question of redemption
that he fails.
See anything else.
He fails to see any one else in his
preoccupation with that problem.
Now I want to switch gears just for the
last couple of minutes and ask you what
do you see?
What do you see when you read this
novel and I'm going to suggest to you
something to think about.
I see body parts.
When I read this novel,
I see a lot of dismembered body parts.
What do I mean by that?
Well,
let's take a look on page 32
try 28 see if you can find it.
This is Hayes coming to
the house of Leroy Watts.
He went up to the front porch and put his
eye to a convenient crack in the shade
and found himself looking
directly at a large white knee.
Yeah,
and what's she doing?
She's cutting her toenails.
Mrs. Watts was sitting alone in a white
iron bed cutting her toenails with a
large pair of scissors.
She was a big woman with very yellow
hair and white skin that glistened with a
greasy preparation she had on a pink
nightgown that would have better fit,
a smaller figure that large white knee.
The way this narration allows us to see
through Hazel's eyes begins to take the
whole body apart.
So what he sees is not Mrs. Watts,
he sees a large white knee.
We saw a version of this also in the
passage I was reading just before where a
hand comes in the window and rests,
lands on Hayes's shoulder,
a square red face,
and then these things,
these body parts are then referred
to with the Pronoun. It, it,
the hand did this or
that. Um, take a look at
page 18.
Yeah,
this is Mrs Hitchcock
in the train is Hayes bumping into
Mrs Hitchcock going around the corner.
He ran into something heavy and pink.
It gasped and muttered clumsy.
It was Mrs Hitchcock and a pink wrapper
with her hair in knots around her head.
She looked at him with her eyes squinted,
nearly shut the knobs,
framed her face like dark toadstools.
She tried to get past him
and he tried to let her,
but they were both moving
the same way each time.
Her face became purpleish
except for little white marks
over it that didn't heat
up.
It's like she's rotting.
There's mushrooms growing on her
figurative mushrooms growing on her head.
Her face is purple except for the white
marks, the white marks or little scars,
acne scars.
Perhaps
she is a p,
a sort of mass of flesh as Mrs. Watts.
That Pink Rapper,
these actually to pee pink
wrappers too tight on their bodies,
suggest the excess of
their corporate reality.
They're big hunks of flesh
on 62
yeah,
we get Hayes's.
An account of Hayes Hayes is a
childhood sin.
He goes into the freak show at the fair
and he joins the crowd where
his father also is there.
We're looking down into a little into a
lowered place where something white was
lying, squirming a little in a box
line with black cloth for a second.
He thought it was a skinned animal
and then he saw it was a woman
on 15 I'm going to skip back to the train.
I'm just going to rack these up for
you and then we'll think about them.
This is Hayes waiting to be seated
in the dining car of the train.
He's hesitated and saw the hand
jerk again, the hand of the steward.
He lurched up the aisle,
falling against two tables on the way
and getting his hand wet in somebody's
coffee.
The steward placed him between uh,
with three young youngish
women dress like parrots.
Their hands were resting on the table,
read speared at the tips.
He sat and looked in front of him.
I'm skipping down a little bit.
Glomerin intense at the neck of the
woman across from him at intervals.
Her hand holding the cigarette
would pass the spot on her neck.
It would go out of its his site
and then it would pass. Again,
going back down to the table,
what do we make of these
odd moments of description?
Why all these body parts hanging around?
Why this sense of disgusting
excessive body matter.
It's often women who appear in this guys,
but it's not always women.
What I want to suggest to you is that
when we actually look at the sentences on
the page,
when we look at the words that O'Connor
chose in the moments of the narration,
we see something that becomes
more complicated than the
Flannery O'connor is a
Catholic writer, haze motes.
Is it Christian mongrave Louie.
That's a kind of focus.
If we think about this and
analogize it to how Hayes looks,
it's a way of looking at our Connor's
fiction that sees nothing but the theology
behind it that sees nothing
but the Christian iconography.
And I want to ask what is it that
we don't see when that's all we see.
What do we miss?
I've be gone to point out a few things
that I think we miss the fragmentation of
bodies. Why our bodies consistently
fragmented, not just here.
Everywhere in O'connor's fiction,
people are always losing
a wooden leg and you know,
having bar parts of their limbs fall off.
It's very hard to keep a
body together in O'Connor.
Hard to keep body and soul to get
well. Well, I won't get into that. Um,
so why is that?
What kind of methodology for reading
would allow us to have something to say
about that. Is it something we need
to have something to say about?
Is it in the same register of importance
in our reading as some of these more
theological structural considerations
that have been offered to us in her
letters and her preface and in the very
overt symbology of the landscape scenes
of these other scenes that I was reading
to you today in that image of the
unhoused believer,
trying to find a home in a an alien world.
So in my next lecture,
what I'm going to do is
pretty much contradiction.
Most of what I said today,
I'm going to set aside theology
as the lens through which I read,
and if you felt you were convinced by
my reading of that iconography in these
passages, then you want to think
about why that's convincing.
Whether you want to think about how much
attention and primacy we should give to
an author, statements about
what her work means as readers.
Maybe you want to say,
you can't argue with that.
We have to accept that.
That's really what the writer intends
to say, and that's what we should see.
And that's what we should
strive to understand. Well,
I'm going to offer you two different ways,
actually more like three different
ways to look at the novel in the second
lecture. So finish the novel
for next Wednesday, and, um,
and we will go from there.